you know having a just cause and working
every day to advance
an idealized state of the future that
for all practical purposes you'll never
reach
you know this is what vision is this is
why we call it vision because you can
imagine it in your mind's eye
you know increasing top line revenues by
x milli billions of dollars
by you know the end of 2025 is not a
vision it's just a goal um
but to advance vision it it takes real
discipline
it's much easier to just set short term
goals and align our incentive structures
to just work on the short term it's
easier
and and i get my bonus quicker um
building trusting teams that's the hard
work of leadership it's so much easier
to just hire and fire people and who
cares you throw enough spaghetti against
the wall eventually it sticks
but to actually spend the hard work of
doing good leadership and worrying about
people as human beings and
how do they feel and are they okay and
are we do we
do we have a productive work environment
like that's hard work and it's
it requires constant attention um
management is just
easier um uh worthy rivalry
you know competition is exciting and fun
and we can set these arbitrary goals and
these arbitrary
metrics and you know we beat them
because look at our market share
you know even though we're losing money
hand over fist um uh
you know it makes people feel good and
the thrill of the thrill of the
competition
but ultimately it forces us to make
decisions that um that that weaken the
company over time
um uh uh existential flex
is is a really stressful uh to to lay
upon a company
you know again we've already invested so
many man hours and so much money why do
we want to walk away from that
investment
because it's the wrong investment that's
why you
well intentioned and you got it wrong it
happens sometimes you know
and cut your losses and change
directions it's really hard to do
especially when you're accountable to
outside forces that don't want to see
you do that they want to hit you you
want to hit the short term numbers
so yeah it requires tremendous courage
to do all these things you know i
understand that the pressures on us
including the incentive structures and
the outside pressures
on most executives is extreme and
overwhelming
we hear it all the time especially in
the public markets you know
every public company executive knows
that wall street
and the analyst community is a big joke
you know they all they all know
that that that regularly massive
pressure is put on put upon them
to make decisions that they know are bad
for the company or to avoid making
decisions that they know are good for
the company and they all shrug
their shoulders and say what am i
supposed to do this is why it takes
courage
there's safety in numbers um so yeah i
cannot even imagine the
the overwhelming pressures especially
that a public company uh ceo must face
on a daily basis
it takes tremendous tremendous courage
to do the right thing and
change an infinite mindset and it's
ultimately good for the people good for
the customer
good for the shareholder uh and good for
the longevity of the company too